Chris Stewart, thanks for talking to Reason.
Hey, thanks for having me, Nick. I appreciate it.
Let's start by talking about the past year in
K -12 education.
I am glad both that I was not a student nor my children are out ofK-12.
So like, I am glad I didn't have to deal with this.
I know you did, but what are the
essential lessons that we should be learning
from the COVID-19 lockdowns about K-12 education?
Well I think one of the most important lessons that we
all learned as parents, those of us who have
kids in the K-12 system, is that government is
not always going to be reliable for us. So this
was the first time in mass that government gave us
our kids back and said, here have at her, because
we have nothing for you right now.
And it was the first time for many parents that they encounteredthe idea that, whoa, wow, I am entirely
responsible for these young people in my house.
And it may have been the first time they had to exercise muscles as parents that they haven't had to exercise before,
because for so many yearseducation has professionalized parents out of the educational equation.
And over periods of time,
it has infantilized parents to the point wherewe can't even imagine being responsible totally
for our kids' education.
And in this last yearbecame abundantly clear government had nothing for us.
They said basically, we'll get back to you.
Right? Here's your kids, we’ll get back to you.